on the topic of tia i don't know if you
had a chance to see this
but we spoke to her right when the world
went into lockdown
yeah i don't know about to cry not to be
able to see my dad
my brothers and my sister has been
pretty hard because we're all very close
you know
i did see it i still haven't seen her
physically
um no i i i six months
no because i live in napa and uh
right when we were actually gonna head
up there there was a surge in l.a
and it wasn't wise for all of us you
know to kind of go there
i recently went down there like recently
we were gonna meet up
she's working on family reunion and the
time
it didn't work but i know for a fact
when we see each other
we're just we're just gonna we're gonna
cry but what we have been doing
is every two weeks we
zoom each other and we
have happy hour so we have a glass of
wine
we talk about you know what's been
happening we
text almost you know every other day but
it's something about
visually seeing your loved one but
there's something even better
obviously just the human connection and
and touch
and and hug and i just i can't
wait to do that is this the longest
you've ever gone in life
um yeah we even we've been we've been
mapping it out we've been like you know
it's been like
it's been like six months or it's been
like and it sucks
i want to bring up another tia moment
that we we more recently had with her
my sister and myself we were huge fans
of this
magazine that was very popular and
basically what was said was i'm sorry
you girls would not sell
because you know we're black i'm curious
if you have the same memory
and um and do you see change happening
in the world
she she's 100 right
that absolutely happened to us
and it was a very
unfortunate sad
confusing time for us because
sister sister at that time was
huge and you know and
it was a magazine that it was a dream
for us to to be on the cover of
and we didn't think we were going to get
any pushback
because of the state of sister sister
like how could you
say no to a very popular
show um that had teenagers on it
they said no and even my publicist at
the time
who you know she was white
at first she didn't tell us why because
she didn't want to hurt our feelings
but my sister and i are the type of
people and as people got to know me
over the years we're very real so
we wanted to know the truth because it
was so confusing
why and she was pissed
the publicist because she knew
it was wrong there was there was no
reason why we shouldn't be on the cover
but what we were told was was
and this is in addition to what what tia
was saying
was that to be black and to be on the
cover we had to be
like a triple threat to sell you
couldn't just
be an actress you had to be um
a a music star a
movie star a so we
we felt like we just weren't enough and
it was like
wow but you would see other people on
the cover who weren't all those things
but we had to be more
and uh you know that hurt yeah i was
gonna say obviously still to this day
you know tia was very emotional when she
was telling that story did it have a
similar impact on you do you still feel
that today
well i mean it's it's unfortunate i hate
to say you get to a point where
you don't want to expect it my mom she
kind of prepped us
through this growing up she said just
know in certain situations because of
the color of your skin
you're going to have to work extra
harder and
obviously in that case that was that was
the truth what we were in that moment
was
was not enough um but what i used it is
is i used it as fuel
i was like okay that's what you think
i'm gonna work i'm gonna work even i'm
gonna work even harder
i feel like now we are having an
uprising
we are on the verge of um
hopefully amazing change i want to get
to a point
where we're we're we're still not saying
the same thing like over and over and
over and over again
we're not gonna take this anymore and
this is what needs to happen this is
what this is what needs to change
sister sister it's on netflix it's so
cool because this new generation
is falling in love with this show and
i'm just curious you know what is it
like for you
to have new kids go up to you on the
street
whoa netflix gave it to the people and
holy crap i feel like i am reliving
when sister sister aired on abc for the
first time
the coolest experience ever i was at a
doctor's appointment
i'm sitting there waiting there was this
preteen
she had a little ipad and she is like
she's with her little brother
she's not looking at anything around her
she is like fixated
she's like not even moving and i hear
sister
sister never knew how much that i missed
you i was like
oh my gosh what if i say something
should i say something should i
what and so i literally said excuse me
hi are you watching sister sister and
she was like
uh-huh and i said i'm tamara
her look she went like this
shocked i don't think
i don't think it really hit her she even
walked out of the office that way
it was surreal it was really cool to see
the younger generation
kind of like loving it just as much as
you know our generation did when it came
on
and what is going on with this revival i
know you guys hit a little bit of a
roadblock
what's the status update i don't know i
we don't
we don't we don't know that's the thing
she is busy working i'm busy working
we have not given up it's it's it's it
seriously depends
on timing and uh
i think the creative idea of it if there
is a reboot in any kind of way a movie
a series or whatever it's going to be
awesome i think it's beautiful that tia
has been posting such beautiful photos
of her natural gray hair yeah what is it
like
you know aging in this industry where
people are discovering you as
you know the young girl in the overall i
know right with the bucket hat
well what i hear a lot is you don't even
look like you're in your
40s correct you look like you're
you know like so it it it is it is a
compliment
i see my mother aging gracefully and
beautifully
uh she taught us the the importance of
accepting your natural beauty and i feel
like
that is what is happening you know as we
as we get
as we get older i i i have gray hair
like at the top right here i'm still at
the
i still like to cover it up every now
and then that's just me
but uh he is embracing it i love that my
sister is you know embracing it
she is stunning and fly and if anything
i can just i look at her and i'm like
yeah that's dope she's owning it and
that's the thing about tia if
if tio you know whatever state tia is
in she she owns that and to be
interviewed
to your daughter how does that feel i
feel old
that's how i feel i'm like whoa it's
like it's it's surreal because in my
mind i still feel like i'm that
that little you know that little girl
and i'm like i can't believe i'm sitting
here
you know talking to my daughter about
this show and i swear she knows how to
find it on her computer
she has her little little little ipad
and again you will hear
sister sister never knew how much i'm
like are you watching sister sister
she's like uh-huh
i like that show i mean is it lost on
you because you know most kids are like
my parents
are embarrassing your daughter is a
legit fan girl
which is weird that's what i'm saying
and then my son said
mommy i want to watch the movie that
you're doing we've watched everything
else that that you were in
we want to watch everything that you're
in so that makes me feel good
that i'm doing things that my children
can
can watch and i'm comfortable with them
with them watching it
and that they are fans knowing that your
daughter
is such a fan would you ever want to see
her step into that role
absolutely she wants to be on tv she
kind of hinted to me
she's five obviously i have to support
her
you know 100 100 so who knows we shall
see
she said she wants to be in one of
mommy's movies so
i the next generation of tea and tamara
campbell
played by ariah and cairo in cairo
[Music]
you